imagine you are working
but halfway through the day
it appears that there is suddenly less work than first thought
may your employer just send you home
no at least not
if these hours are not subsequently paid
the labor market law in balance
is included
that there is a certain call term
this is four days in advance
according to the law
and in some collective labor agreements there is 24
made hours in advance
in practice this means that we are less than 24
hours or less than four days in advance
before your shift starts
your working hours are changed
after all,
you have already started your work
and you are scheduled for certain hours
you can expect to be able to work these hours
and not suddenly halfway through the day
sent home with less hours
so if your employer you in the future
want to send away earlier
because there is less work than planned
it is best to go home
you have the right to be paid those hours